okay well Dr Zakia in the morning of the
Eid uh is a requirement for the Muslims
to go out and uh do the Eid prayer could
you explain for the benefit of myself
and the viewers what are the rulings
regarding the Eid
prayer as far as the prayer for Eid is
concerned I love it Prophet M wasallam
said it's mentioned in say Muslim marume
number two in the book of fasting Hadith
number 2534
abua with me said that the prophet muham
wasallam he said that fasting is
prohibited on two days
on
and that mean the two days
of that breaking of The Fast and E day
of that the E day of sacrifice these two
days is prohibited so no one can fast on
these two days as far as the ruling is
concerned about the Salah for there are
difference of opinion amongst the
scholar
and the different schools of thought
according to Imam Shafi and Imam Malik
the Shafi and the malakis they say that
the E Salah is
a it is a very important Sunnah known as
must based on the Hadith that there
bedin who comes and says that Allah
subhana wa tala has not made us
compulsory any Salah other then the five
prescribed Salah which is mentioned in M
volume number two page number 2 to3 So
based on this Hadith that no other Salah
is compul besides the five times
prescribed Salah they said that this
Salah
of and it
is according to the hum school of
thought the humies they say it
is that means a f as long as some people
from the community do it it's enough
it's not F on every indiv idual for and
the third ruling that is according to IM
Abu hanifah may Allah have mercy on him
he said that it is it is vaj and this
view is also
of that praying Salah and Salah it is
and the ruling is based on the ver of
the Quran
of chapter number 108 verse number two
which says
means and turn to the Lord in prayer and
sacrifice so it indicate that you have
to offer the E Salah
of and then
sacrifice So based on this world they
say it is compulsory to offer the E
Salah and there are various other in
which prophet M wasallam has
commanded the Muslims that they should
offer Salah not only to the general
Muslims even to the women who are
minrating he said go for it Salah even
if you don't have to offer Salah he said
the veil woman even the Virgin whether
they are young or matur they should go
for each Salah and the minrating women
even if they can't offer they should at
least go to the Mah it's mentioned
inkari number one in the book of Salah
Hadith number 351 as well asth number 3
to 4 and various of the hadiths the
prophet even said that the children
should go
and based on this Hadith IM Abu hanifah
may Allah Havey on him
and may Havey on him too they said that
offering Salah is there's one moreth in
Abu da number one in the book of Salah
Hadith number
1068 where the Beloved Prophet M
wasallam
said that we have two eats together that
is f and the jum Salah even jum is
supposed to be a weekly so he says
that after offering
the Salah he says that those who do not
want to offer J Salah may not do it if
they don't want to but we will offer J
Salah indicating that because you
offered jum Salah which is more
important than the five prescribed
Salah here Prophet said if you offer in
congregation Salah not be offered that
day but naturally they have to offer the
normal D Salah so this surely indicates
that
isah and agree with the view of Imam Abu
hanifah may Allah have mercy on him as
well as may Allah have mercy on him too
a mean inshallah and of course it's such
a wonderful opportunity for the Muslims
to gather and you know feel good about
themselves and we need lots of
opportunities to feel good about
ourselves right now inshallah